the jurogan experience
well it's an honor to meet you derek
especially after such high praise so
tell me your story like how did what
happened to you
well thanks for having me and josh
thanks for the accolades
um you know i was 17 year old kid
running around brooklyn at a time when
brooklyn was uh terrible
and i was a product of my environment i
was doing little robberies and you know
a little stump stuff that adolescents do
and i got on the
radar police department
uh they used to search me all the time
pat me down you know throw me up on the
car regular stuff that happened in that
community um one day
uh a man was killed about 5 a.m by some
older guys in the neighborhood
the police had the identification of the
car
they called the guy in and he
somehow told them he rented me the car
and that i was the one that bought the
car back and told him that i had
committed the crime and that i had shot
the guy by accident
um and that was my first real experience
with the criminal justice system because
it was a murder
um i'm like murder you know i did a
couple of robberies i you know i did
some petty stuff but murder that's not
me
so um you know what was amazing to me is
number one
um nobody would have gave me their car
at 17 years old right any cop would have
known that this guy would have gave me
his car
um but they arrested me and they charged
me with murder
and i was convicted
by a jury because they admitted grand
jury testimony of a witness who came
before the court and said i never seen
this guy at all the police made me lie
in the grand jury and say that i seen
this guy i'm not testifying i refuse to
testify i'm not going to get up there
and purging myself
uh the judge told the prosecutor that
day that they were dismissing the case
that if they don't get another witness
this case is going out of here um
judge's name was lombardo back then this
was 1983.
um i went back to righteous island that
day we came back the next day and the
judge said that he thought about this
all night
and he felt that the only person would
benefit from this witness not testifying
would be me
therefore he was going to allow the
prosecutor to admit their grand jury
testimony as evidence in chief at my
trial and i would forfeit my right to
confront the witness and let the jury
hear the truth that she never saw the
crime so that was my first real
experience i was a young knucklehead the
lawyer that i had at the time candace
kurtz said look young man get your head
out your ass and you better read these
cases and you better see what's going on
like they arrowed you she took the stand
and told the judge what the witness told
her
um and and i was convicted i was
sentenced to 25 years life
um and it was
at that moment that i know that i had to
study law that i had to really dig deep
in in the books and i did it new york
state uh thank god had
a law library they had all the books in
the world all you had to supply yourself
and i spent the next five and six years
working on my case
uh in 1987 the appellate division in
that case found that the judge had no
evidence whatsoever that me or anybody
acting on my behalf had threatened this
witness did anything improper and that
the judge was right there was no
evidence that that can prove that so
they reversed the conviction and i was
able to get out of prison
uh after six and a half years
unbeknownst to me there was a rogue cop
by the name of louis scarcella
who felt that i didn't do enough time
for this conviction he didn't like the
appellate division decision
eight months later
i was in new haven connecticut at a
unisex line that i had on at the time
he came in that store and arrested me
told me i was going back to brooklyn for
a murder
um and i'm like murder like this can't
be true like again like how many times
has happened i went to new york
um i was processed uh about a year later
i went to trial i was convicted they
brought a witness in by the name of jew
smith who said that she was present at
the murder when her boyfriend was killed
that i was a gunman i had a gun in my
hand and i shot this individual several
times with this gun
but her original statement to the police
said she wasn't there
that she never saw this crime she was
around the corner at a store when she
came back her boyfriend was dead the
jury never heard that statement but in
any event
the ballistics evidence proved
that this guy was shot with two
different guns that he wasn't shot in
the building when she said he was shot
at but he was shot outside in the street
despite this evidence i was convicted
after i was convicted was when i learned
that she had first told the cops at the
crime scene she never saw the crime but
she had told her to a different
detective so i made a proceeding motion
to set aside the verdict and in the
motion i argue that this detective that
never came in that she gave the
statement to could prove my innocence
and the judge ordered a hearing for a
year he said i can't give this guy a day
in jail
let alone
uh 15 years which is the minimum i want
this witness to come back the prosecutor
said i'm not calling him and the judge
said if you don't call her back
this case is going to a new trial right
they called the bat and she admitted
that she never saw the crime that the
detective louis scott stella told her
what happened and told her that if she
didn't get up here and say that i
committed the crime she was going to
jail she was on parole her boyfriend was
a felon that just got out she had kids
they said you're going to jail she said
what was i supposed to do here's the
system telling me this that if i don't
come in and say this i'm going to jail
and i came in and said it
the judge ruled a year later that
again he felt that i was
he said there was a common thread of
strings i manipulated this evidence
again i called the detective
the detective came in and said exactly
what the witness said
that she told him she didn't see the
crime that she was beat up
and took to the priest and then told she
was going to jail now had that jury
heard that there'd have been different
results
at the at the trial they told the jury
that her first statement was the most
important statement in this case and
then when the police arrived on the
scene she didn't hesitate she said
derrick hamilton somebody i know my
entire life committed a crime which
wasn't true in fact she said the truth
was she didn't see the crime that she
was somewhere else
um i was sentenced to 25 years of life
i found numerous post-conviction motions
after post-conviction motions every time
a judge gave me a hearing every time he
said he can throw the case out every
time he said he was troubled by this
conviction uh the prosecutor would come
in and tell him a bad guy that this is
not somebody you want to release that
you know they put imagine harms that
make a judge think that i was the most
terrible person in the world and he was
denied emotion every single time
um you know i felt numerous emotions
numerous post convictions i did
everything you could imagine
to prove my innocence but to no avail
i began going to parole board around
2009
it was a very traumatic experience for
me because at that time the parole board
wanted me to admit guilt and i wasn't
going to do that i'm not gonna come in
and say i killed somebody didn't kill
i'm not doing that i don't care what you
say and i had to challenge them and
fight them for two years
uh and then my family went out and
protest and we got a daily news article
put out that said that i would be free
if the court would just basically give
me justice if they just give this guy a
fair shot he'd be home so it changed the
the mentality of the parole board they
looked at all of my evidence and they
said you know based on the evidence that
you presented here um we believe in your
innocence like this evidence speaks for
itself even the judge said you was
innocent i don't know what you're doing
here all these years and they released
me and at that point i began a crusade
because when i was in prison there were
several guys we built something called
the actual innocence team guys who i was
working in the library so i would read
god's case and check them out so what i
had to do was
get families together get people to come
together and bring their families and
say look let's send these people to city
hall let them know there's a lot of us
in here it's not just me it's white
there's black there's a bunch of us in
here that got the same issue that
they're procedurally borrowing us
they're not looking at our case just
kicking it into the garbage we don't
want to hear it get out of here right
because they can they had the power so
we started bringing attention to these
cases it changed the whole dynamic so
when i got out i joined that group
family and friends of the romans
convictions uh we had the pr guy by the
name of lonnie suri who was helping us
keep it together and we just began
blasting the prosecutors we began
protesting outside the offices and
getting rid of them while the first one
we was able to get rid of was charles
hines in brooklyn the prosecutor that
sent me to prison he was able to remove
him and put a progressive prosecutor in
that agreed that he would look at
these convictions if he was elected so
he got in and in two years he examined
22 people
and he found that it was a systemic
racist problem in brooklyn that was
convicting the wrong people
uh fortunately for me uh the new york
times reporter called me and i believe
it's 2012.
and they said why are people afraid of
the police
i just said are you kidding me why are
they afraid of the police
and i told them names of guys that i
knew that was in prison that this cop
set up
and a lawyer had contacted me and said
that he was working on a case which this
cop framed another guy by the name of
david ranta and he said in two weeks
there's going to be an article in new
york times that exposed this cop and i
told the new york times reporter that
and i said look two weeks if it comes
out you come back to me and i'll take
you to these guys and she came back
francis roberts she came back and i took
it to these guys she got the prosecutor
to agree to look at 50 of these cops
cases
50 of them and um you know 20 was
exonerated so far those guys and i was
exonerated in 2015. in 2014 for the
first time in uh new york history the
appellate division second department
ruled in my case that a free standing
action innocence claim can be recognized
under post-conviction motion and they
said that anybody that's innocent the
courts could no longer procedurally
bother you they got to reach the merits
of your contentions they just can't say
well you should have raised this before
or your lawyer failed to do this before
or you should have did you got to reach
the merits of it get to the bottom line
this guy innocent or not and when they
gave me that opinion it kind of like in
itself exonerated because the prosecutor
now had to hear my witnesses i had
alibis i had police officers who said
look this guy was in new haven
connecticut not brooklyn when this
murder happened we know because we've
seen him there he was at a party with
him at a hotel receives i had many
witnesses that could verify where i was
that on the day that daniel cash was
murdered the courts were just throwing
the evidence in the garbage we in fact
proved who committed the crime
the real murderer was present when the
cops arrived he was on parole for
manslaughter they took his name down but
never even investigated who he was so we
had a lot of we had a witness who was
there who identified who was there
identified why the guy was shot there
was a 911 caller said three male blacks
fleeing in the red car he admitted they
were in the red car so they were just
overwhelming evidence of my innocence
but quartz was just throwing it in the
garbage because of the prosecutor lied
to them and said he's a bad guy so my
experience has taught me that you know
there's a lot of innocent people i was
in prison man look one thing about
prison and i tell people they say hey
everybody says the innocence that's not
true right they may tell a lawyer that
but they're not going to tell a guy in
the neighborhood with them that i know
you're guilty you know i was with you i
know what you did you told me everybody
tells me from the same neighborhoods so
it's a small minority of people that's
in the law library every single day
if you go to the yard guys is working
out in the way pal right they're playing
basketball but the innocent guy is in
that law library every single day trying
to find a way out and that was me
um every single day and i studied every
book in there i taught law classes um
and i became very good at it i mean i
was surprised that i mean i didn't go to
college right when the lawyer gave me
the first two cases and i read them i
was surprised how well i knew the cases
i was surprised how i comprehended him
and it was because of that um that i
kept going and i found the civilian who
liked me uh he was working a little
library and the first test i got was a
44 and he said look man i'm not going to
waste my time you got to explain what
that is what a 44.
uh a 44 was my grade on the test
um i particular test the first test he
gave me was on the constitution of the
united states i had to learn the fourth
fifth sixth eighth and fourteenth
amendment um and i i failed i was
playing and he said look you're not
gonna waste my time you're smarter than
that he challenged me next time i came
back i got a 97. so from that point on i
just started studying i started start
you know gravitating to the older guys
that knew more than me uh because i was
young they was willing to teach me and i
was like a young sponge and i just i
just loved what i did i became
passionate about it and that's why i'm
here now derek what kind of
repercussions are there for cops that do
things like this none i mean
in our case
uh the statute of limitations that ran
out on this cop and let me just tell you
about this cop he didn't just do it in
the police department he left the police
department went into the d.o.e
department of education and he did it
there he framed the gun and the doe
they later found out the guy did nothing
wrong he had to reinstate him this is
just his nature and his character um and
he just gets away with it he gets away
what's his name louis scarcella and he's
out there still he's out there he's
still getting the pension the city is
still paying this guy we still got cases
today that we are fighting in court for
him james jenkins nelson cruz are they
still actual cases that we litigating
how many people do you think that guy
wrongfully put in prison you know i'll
tell you something did i even tell you
josh about this one and it's gonna
this guy
worked on over 200 cases
my father was killed in 1988.
he was the detective on that case
um and i'll tell you something about
that um
he said that one of the guys
snatched a confession on his hand and
ate it
i didn't believe that
i said as much as i want people who may
be responsible for my father i can't
trust this guy
i can't take nothing he say to be truth
right just recently that case was
overturned samuel edmondson case because
of his
sloppy police work
so i he says 200 cases he worked on i
would like to believe at least half of
those guys
uh are innocent well a lot of them have
been exonerated how many scarcell
exonerations have there been 20 today
how does a guy not just get locked up
immediately for that
and when he testifies and when he
testifies he has two lawyers with him
now
right i've never seen a witness come to
court
and have two lawyers standing with him
we object to it all the time
but i mean this is how much a criminal
he is he had two lawyers standing with
them all the time
um trying to protect his rights and he
don't remember anything now like he
don't remember you know of course you
don't recall nothing uh you got to bring
the police reports to him and says
that's your singing [ __ ] did you do this
but he don't remember anything of course
selectively you don't even need
you